Jennifer we go
we're slowly maybe where are we really
going we're going to the Grove why are
we going to the Grove Maggiano's but I
have a feeling we're not gonna end up
going to machi on it what but this is
what's gonna happen that's gonna suit
cheesy factory soon as he gets there he
sits right next door to Barnes & Noble
and he's gonna get super pumped up about
it and all he's gonna be talking about
is a chicken parmesan sandwich well he
just had chicken parm yesterday that
doesn't I know crap we should make a
reservation shouldn't say then we have
to go there you're right with you last
time from the stereo
oh my god I can't believe nadeshot gonna
be here how do we get there
this is my favorite food why is it so
hot up here you guys can't tell but it's
like 95 degrees yeah
it's official friendzone I don't know
anything we just left Matt's book
signing Wow wild times wild times so I
didn't even realize is usually when you
go to like CES and things like that you
can't actually buy things but here you
can actually buy the things that you see
which is could be dangerous
here's a little backdrop we take a
picture and then it brings it out
hi my name's Davis I'm a photo clonic
came to me Justine nice offer
it was the quiet venture back in 2010 in
November and I was really excited when I
found out my phone vo to meet her so we
just finished the meetup now I'm kind of
just wandering around and I
DT is I met one guy who was absolutely I
just remember seeing this video this
girl who crashed your drone and it was
so durable but now I definitely want to
get one Leila's used to going to
beautycon it's a little bit different
this is wrong
like all these delicious treats and
they're not edible we need to go get
waffles immediately ready let's go let's
go get the waffles I think it was an
Instagram Sammy's posted a picture of
this churros bar we work so awesome
that's incredible right
so clearly we had incredible time at
photos on but I will say they have a
fine selection of food trucks you
believe like actually can
I'm not proud of it but I'm also not mad
about it so who do you guys on the other
side just saw back from photo con and
Jenna and I are gonna go fly drones I'm
so excited it's the weekend so cheers to
the freakin weekend but gonna have us
some phone I have my old phantom 3 the
Jenna's gonna fly so I've got to find it
and get all the batteries charged up I
have it open up the standing period a
while she looks great
okay I'm gonna set up all the drones
then we're gonna go flying in I'm gonna
edit this video before we leave so all
of the videos that you're gonna see of
us flying the drones will be maybe in
tomorrow or the next day's video wish us
luck because we're gonna need it
oops the recording huh